(bright music)
We're gonna turn our attention back
to behavioral medicine,
but Dr. Heinrich, of course, is back,
and he's gonna take it over for behavioral medicine II.
Thank you, sir.
All right, so we'll talk about bipolar disorder
and anxiety disorders here.
Nothing to disclose on these topics either.
What we're gonna talk is about the differential diagnosis
and clinical presentation of bipolar disorder
and anxiety disorders, and surprise, surprise,
we're gonna follow that
by talking about some treatment recommendations
for them from a pharmacotherapy
and a non-pharmcotherapy standpoint.
Again, I have Dr. Oakley to thank,
Stan, for the basis of these slides,
which I've built on.
So let's start with AES.
Which is of the following true about bipolar disorder:
kindling is the acceleration of untreated mood swings;
bipolar disorder occurs more commonly in men than women;
bipolar II is characterized by depression, along with mania;
and patients with bipolar II may both have manic
and hypomanic episodes, along with their depression?
Ooh, I did this one good. All right.
All right, so we have a little mix between A and B,
and we'll kind of go through the talk and answer that here.
Nice, I find when talking about bipolar disorder,
it's best to define different mood states
because they're very relevant to the diagnosis of bipolar.
So we're gonna talk about what mania is.
We're gonna talk about what hypomania is,
what it looks like.
We've already talked a little bit about depression,
and then we're gonna talk about mixed mood states.
So what is mania?
Mania requires that the patient either has an irritable
or euphoric mood,
along with increased goal-directed activity or energy.
So they can be irritable, irritable manics are not pleasant.
Grandiose manics can be a little bit more fun
when you're talking to them,
but they have these cardinal symptoms of mania,
and if it's manic grandiosity, they need three symptoms,
but if it's an irritable type,
they need four of these cardinal symptoms,
and I'll talk about those in my next slides.
For mania, they have to have these symptoms present
for at least a week,
unless they get psychiatrically hospitalized before that,
that counts, okay?
And these patients have significant social,
educational, employment dysfunction associated
with this mania episode.
These are those cardinal symptoms.
The mnemonic is DIG FAST.
They're very distractable, they're quite impulsive
with rapid traveling and spending,
they can be very grandiose
with thoughts about being the next coming of Jesus,
or inventing the next great
Nobel Prize winning physics advancement,
they can have flight of ideas in which they jump
from topic to topic during the conversation,
and you're left mouth agape kind of difficulty,
kind of wondering what's going on.
They can have a lot of goal-directed activities.
They're writing the next great play,
at the same time a novel,
at the same time they're working three jobs,
and cleaning and raising children.
Not well necessarily, but trying.
They're not sleeping.
And unlike depressed patients who aren't sleeping,
they're not tired.
They don't need to sleep, okay?
And they're very talkative,
much like me trying to fit all of this into 30 minutes.
All right, how does that differentiate
from a hypomanic episode?
Well, it differs in level of severity.
They still need those criteria.
A grandiose hypomanic still needs three
of those cardinal symptoms,
and an irritable still needs four, but it's not,
they don't have the significant level of impairment.
They're able to maintain a job.
They may get warnings, but they're able,
they're not like escorted out
when they come in completely manic, okay?
And fired on the spot.
So there is impairment, but not significant impairment.
The episode duration is shorter.
They can be only four days.
They don't need that entire week,
but it's still a change in behavior
that's observable by others.
These patients do not get psychotic,
and if they get psychotic, they bump up to mania.
Depression, the depressed mood state we just talked about,
in bipolar disorder,
it's the same criteria we use for major depression.
You don't have to memorize new things or anything like that.
However, if somebody has a depressive,
meets those criteria and has a history of hypomania
or mania, they bounce into bipolar category.
No longer major depressive disorder.
Now, mixed episodes are terrible episodes for patients.
They are both irritable, and grandiose,
and depressed at the same time.
They meet criteria for both a manic episode,
and both a depressed episode at the same time.
Can you imagine being clinically depressed,
but having all the energy in the world
and not feeling like you need to sleep?
That's gotta be terrible, and it is terrible.
It's associated with a higher risk of suicide
than other bipolar mood states.
So not a pleasant experience.
So with that understanding of the mood states,
we can switch to talk actually about the diagnostic criteria
of bipolar I and bipolar II.
So if you have a history of a manic episode,
you have bipolar I.
Not very hard, okay?
That's the diagnosis.
If you've had a manic episode, you have bipolar I.
It can't be explained by hyperthyroidism
or something else, but you have bipolar I.
This is kind of what it looks like.
You have the manic episodes that reach that red line,
and you have the depressive episodes,
but you actually don't need a depressive episode
to get a diagnosis of bipolar I.
We'll see that a vast, vast, vast majority do,
but you don't necessarily need it.
I don't think I've ever seen anybody
who hasn't had a major depressive episode,
but you theoretically could.
So they kind of cycle between this manic and depressive,
hence the old name of manic depressive illness.
It's a very chronic disease, unfortunately, and reoccurring,
and this is where the concept of kindling comes in.
The concept of kindling is
if they have more untreated mood episodes,
the likelihood of the next one comes on quicker,
is more severe and more difficult to treat.
The brain just gets kind of used to that,
so it kindles and the episodes become more frequent
and more severe.
Really stresses the importance of diagnosing
and treating as quickly as possible.
The average length of depression is a little longer
than in major depression, with about six to 12 months,
whereas mania is a little shorter, up to three months.
That's if you don't do anything and just kind of watch this.
It's got actually a fairly low prevalence.
This prevalence has been increasing
as the diagnostic criteria tends to get
a little bit more sophisticated.
It's less than 1%, with an equal rate
between male and female of one to one.
The mean age of onset is about 18 years of age,
so right around early adulthood,
but it does occur throughout the life span.
I will tell you that if I'm seeing somebody
at age 55 or 60 that has no history of mania or depression
and is coming across as manic,
they're getting maybe not quite a million-dollar workup
for other causes, but I'm getting a call from somebody
about how expensive my workup is.
I alluded to the fact that I've really never seen somebody
with just a manic episode.
They often will have another manic episode or a depressive.
That's because 90% of patients after a manic episode
will go on to develop another mood state,
major depressive and mania.
Bipolar II, they cannot have any history
of a manic episode, okay?
They can only have that hypomanic episode,
and they do need a past episode of major depression
to have that diagnosis, or, at some point,
they'll have that diagnosis.
The rate is a little bit more than bipolar I, at 0.8.
So between the two, you're at about 1.4, 1.5.
And the clinical data really does suggest,
unlike bipolar I, it's more prevalent in women than in men.
Usually begins with a depressive course.
About 70% of them start with depression,
and then they go on to, in the future,
develop that kind of hypomania.
The number of episodes, the different mood states
between depression and hypomania are more than in bipolar I,
so there's a more frequent switch,
but the really good news is there isn't this progression
to bipolar I.
Patients with bipolar II tend to stay at bipolar II,
with only 10, 15% progressing onto bipolar I,
so that's actually pretty good news.
And this is what it looks like.
They never get up to that high manic state,
but they do hit the depressive state, okay?
Red and blue.
Now, cyclothymia, I have never diagnosed it,
I have never seen it diagnosed,
but I have seen it on a board question,
not as the primary, but as a confounder,
so it's included here.
So kind of like that persistent depressive,
this is a prolonged mood state.
For over two years, there's been symptoms of hypomania,
but never meeting the criteria of hypomania,
and symptoms of depression, but never meeting the criteria
for major depression for two years.
The real key aspect is you're getting a history
that they've never clicked all the boxes
for hypomania, mania or depression to actually get this,
but still have this kind of cycling
around this midline of euthymic state.
Again, I don't know. I've never seen it.
As we're continuing this trend as depression as a symptom
that requires a differential diagnosis,
the same as for mania.
I mentioned bipolar disorder can occur
throughout the lifespan, but if I'm seeing a patient
that's older and doesn't have a history of mood disturbance,
I'm taking a serious look across the spectrum.
I'm looking at medications.
By far, the most common medication for mania is steroids.
40 milligrams of prednisone.
Anything over 40 milligrams of prednisone increases the risk
of neuropsychiatric side effects,
in a very dose dependent manner.
So you see very high doses, you can see mania with steroids.
Drugs of abuse are usually the stimulant type.
Neurological disorders, probably one of the more common ones
are temporal lobe epilepsy.
Epilepsy can present with mania.
Endocrine disorders, hyperthyroidism is
kind of the no-brainer, but interestingly,
also hypothyroidism has been linked
to mania, bipolar disorder.
Infectious diseases, kind of the prototypical one
is herpes encephalitis, has that change in personality
that often comes across as very manic.
And then autoimmune diseases,
probably the real cool autoimmune disease right now
is autoimmune encephalitis.
Have any of you read the book, "My Brain on Fire"
and stuff like that?
Yeah, really cool book,
so I encourage people to take a look at that.
It's a biological presenting very psychiatrically.
All right, so another question here,
which is true about the treatment of bipolar disorder:
valproate is effective for both acute mania
and patients who have rapid cycles;
women with bipolar disorder can continue valproate
if they become pregnant, and it's been effective;
lithium has not demonstrated an impact on suicide risk
in bipolar disorder;
and lithium is hepatically metabolized?
All right, really good.
So A is the right answer, and I'm glad I'm given the talk
because 39 people answering B is too many,
so we're gonna talk about that,
in regards to valproate and pregnancy,
and even valproate in the context
of women of childbearing age.
So goal of the treatment of bipolar is, one,
to do that assessment to look for a differential diagnosis
and address those.
Number two is really taking,
addressing the mood-destabilizing property.
If somebody's manic, I wanna treat their mania
without making them depressed in overshooting
and making them depressed.
If somebody's depressed,
I don't wanna overshoot and make them manic,
and if somebody's in a maintenance phase and euthymic,
I don't wanna cause an exacerbation in either direction,
so we'll address that.
So these are the medications that have been approved
for the various states by the FDA.
And you can kind of see we have more for hypomania,
quite little for depression in the context of bipolar,
and some for maintenance,
but what's disappointing is I only found two
that go across all three of those, okay?
You have Olanzapine, which I don't tend to use
because of its metabolic sequelae,
and you have quetiapine,
which I'm a little bit more comfortable with using,
much more comfortable with using
in these patient populations.
But we do know lithium is effective for depression.
It's got an FDA approval for maintenance,
and we think valproate is also effective
for depression and maintenance,
so we have that available as well.
Sometimes we have to think about the patient's
underlying medical illnesses
to allow us to pick a medication.
So I tend to avoid lithium in renal disease.
I tend to think twice about giving valproate
in somebody with bad liver disease.
If they're already obese or on the threshold of diabetes,
I tend to stay very clear of olanzapine.
If they have a tendency to extrapyramidal side effects,
I won't use aripiprazole or Risperdal.
And women of childbearing age,
whether they're pregnant or not,
I won't use valproate,
unless they're on a fairly permanent birth control,
then it's a consideration.
And if somebody has bipolar disorder,
I don't use unopposed antidepressants, if at all possible.
I'll use an antidepressant potentially,
but they're on another mood stabilizer, okay?
So lithium, we'll go through each of these.
Benefits, it's probably got the best history
for the treatment of bipolar disorder.
It reduces risk of mania and depression.
It's the only bipolar medication that's been shown
to reduce suicide in patients with bipolar disorder.
What's nice is it's not hepatically metabolized,
so I don't have to worry about all those P450 interactions.
Unfortunately, it's only renally excreted,
so I have to worry about lots of medications
that may impair its renal excretion,
and we'll talk about that in the next slide.
And it has a very narrow therapeutic index.
These are some of the more common side effects.
The biggest one is experiences tremor,
but we have to follow longitudinally
their thyroid condition,
as well as a BMP looking for kidney disease
as we're following that.
As people have been on it, it's usually once
or twice a year we'll check these levels going forward.
Psychiatrists are usually pretty good.
It's been drilled into them to check these,
but it's always good, as a primary care provider,
that if they're on these
and you have a shared medical record with the psychiatrist,
that these are documented.
It has a narrow therapeutic index, 0.6 to 1.2,
and even a little above that 1.2,
you start getting nausea and tremor,
impaired renal function, and impaired renal function
impairs the excretion of lithium even more quite rapidly.
Unless you change the dose,
you can develop pretty significant toxicity
that can lead to delirium, coma, and death.
So we tend to be very careful
about co-administering different medications.
Chronic NSAIDs can impair the excretion.
I will tell you, the addition of a thiazide diuretic
to lithium will double the level.
That's where I've seen the most issues with toxicity.
One of the individuals that came up to talk to me
was talking about the importance of shared medical records.
I really think that that speaks
to the importance of shared medical records.
You would need to know that the patient's on lithium,
the psychiatrist needs to know
the patient may be on hydrochlorothiazide
kind of going forward.
ACE inhibitors have been noted to increase lithium levels,
but usually in patients who already have
decreased renal function or are dehydrated.
I consider that fairly safe.
And then thyroid function, we have to monitor.
Valproate, its benefit has to do,
it works for mania and depression, like lithium.
It's safer to use, from a therapeutic index.
We'll talk a little bit about that.
And it seems to be superior to lithium, at least,
for patients with that rapid, cycling,
irritable type of bipolar disorder.
That's why it was the right answer.
The risks are teratogenicity,
physical and kind of behavioral,
and we'll talk a little bit about that.
It's also an issue for just women of childbearing
because of polycystic ovarian disease is really common
in patients on chronic valproate as well,
so we like to really avoid it in that patient population.
Its levels are 60 to 120.
You check a level within four days
before their morning dose.
I will tell you, for those of you that are following these,
whether it's for epilepsy or bipolar,
if you have an elderly patient
who may be a little cachectic or malnourished,
don't check the total levels.
Check the free levels
that take the protein out of the picture.
That'll give you a more accurate representation
of their risk of toxicity,
and that range is six to 12.
Depakote can impact platelets and WBC,
so we check CBCs intermittently,
as well as liver function tests.
Of note here, this hyper ammonia state,
unlike with patients with alcoholic liver disease,
patients on valproate don't need liver impairment
to get elevated ammonias.
So if you have somebody who's coming in more confused,
lethargic, you check their level, their level's fine,
check an ammonia level.
Look to see if that's high.
Atypical antipsychotics in bipolar disorder
are becoming more and more commonly used
because they're easier to use.
I don't have to monitor blood levels.
I can titrate them faster.
I can actually initiate some at a therapeutic dose.
I don't have to taper or titrate anything.
They're easier to use in patients
that may have renal and hepatic function.
I just take that into account
as I'm initiating dose and titrating,
and commonly they're used in conjunction
with a more typical mood stabilizer
like lithium or like valproate.
The risks are primarily those of an antipsychotic.
They're extrapyramidal symptoms.
Olanzapine and quetiapine
have pretty significant metabolic sequelae,
olanzapine, logarithmically, more than quetiapine,
but it's still an issue and does require blood work
when you're prescribing atypical antipsychotics
to monitor for their glucose,
to monitor their HDL and LDL kind of going forward.
And then as we just heard with the speaker before me,
the QT prolongation concerns with these medications
are a real thing that we have to take into account.
So switching gears from bipolar disorder
and the treatment to anxiety disorders,
we're gonna focus on four, primarily panic-specific phobia,
social as well as generalized anxiety disorder,
but we're gonna start out with a question here.
We have a young woman who presents
with three to four panic attacks every week.
With that, deciding that she has a panic disorder,
which would be your pharmacotherapy of choice:
as needed quetiapine; scheduled buspirone;
as needed alprazolam, a benzodiazepine;
or scheduled sertraline?
Yeah, the answer here,
and it's what you guys are getting,
are the scheduled sertraline, I'm very glad.
As needed alprazolam is a little bit lower,
but we'll talk about why that could be.
So anxiety disorders are amazingly common.
About 18% of individuals are affected in any given year,
and about 25%, about 30%, rather,
over the course of their lives
will suffer from an anxiety disorder.
Patients, very much like depressed patients,
don't often present with, "I'm sad and unhedonic."
They present with somatic complaints.
That's even more true for anxiety disorders.
With over 90% of patients with anxiety disorders,
not coming to you saying, "I'm anxious or fearful,"
they're coming to you saying,
"I feel like I have palpitations.
I feel like my heart is racing, or I'm short of breath."
So they're coming to see us in primary care,
not our colleagues in behavioral health often,
so it's important that we're making these diagnoses.
And three of the four diagnoses we're gonna cover,
are pretty common in primary care,
based on this Wayne Katon study.
Between six and 8% of patients
will have either generalized anxiety disorder or social.
So we talked a little bit about the PHQ-9.
How many are using the GAD-2 and GAD-7
in your clinical practices?
That's great.
I'm actually waiting for the USPF services task force
to come up with this recommendation.
There's a GAD-2.
You ask these two questions to screen for anxiety disorders,
and if it's positive, we move to the GAD-7.
Same cutoff level of 10 or more,
with pretty so-so sensitivity and specificity.
The important thing to realize is the GAD-7 was designed
to study generalized anxiety disorder by itself,
so you see a little dilution of its sensitivity
because we're kind of looking at other disorders
with it now.
But it really is the standard for screening
for anxiety disorders in primary care across populations.
But it does have sensitivity and specificity data
for the others, if you're interested in it.
So what is a panic attack?
A panic attack is a discreet period
of intense fear or anxiety
that kind of comes out of the blue,
tends to peak after about 10 minutes,
and then gradually kind of dissipates.
It can be triggered by a stimulus,
but it can also come out of the blue.
Some people actually wake up with panic disorders,
straight out of their sleep and have it.
In addition, how that anxiety comes through
is at least four symptoms,
primarily surrounding autonomic arousal.
It's tachycardia, it's palpitations, it's chest pain,
it's shortness of breath, it's GI distress,
it's nausea, it's feelings of paresthesia.
It's psychological symptoms of, "I'm dying."
It's impending doom or derealization.
"I feel like I'm outside of my body."
It's some cluster of four of those symptoms.
And panic attacks can really happen in any disorder,
depression, generalized anxiety disorder,
but they can also happen in panic disorder,
and panic disorder is when you have panic attacks,
but these panic attacks are followed
by at least one month of, you know, concern
about what these attacks mean.
"Am I having a stroke? Am I having a heart attack?"
There's concern about having another episode in the future.
And sometimes the concern about having another episode
in the future leads individuals to change their lifestyle.
"I've had three panic attacks at the grocery store.
I am not going to that grocery store anymore," okay?
That's a change in their type of behavior,
and those three issues are required
for the diagnosis of a panic disorder.
It's actually fairly common, 1.5 to 3.5.
Much more common, two to three times more common
in women than in men.
And it's often quite a chronic disease.
It may get worse in periods of stress.
Take-home point is over 90% have a psychiatric comorbidity.
Most of those psychiatric comorbidities
are other anxiety disorders,
but a good 10 to 30% have major depressive disorder.
And the good news is that pharmacotherapy are SSRIs,
or SNRIs, two birds, one stone,
the depression and the anxiety.
And then cognitive behavioral therapy.
Again, that's usually the answer on the test.
If somebody's asking about a therapy question,
it's appropriate for these disorders
just like it is for depression.
Now, generalized anxiety disorder is what my wife,
who is a psychiatrist, says I got
when my daughter started dating.
That affect you have when you hear
that my children have both parents as psychiatrist,
that's pity, so that's what my kids often remind us of here.
So why she thought I had this is I had excessive anxiety
and worry, according to her, more days than not,
for at least the first six months of her dating life.
Surrounding that, I actually corrected her,
it's only about the dating,
so it actually fails the criteria based on multiple events,
but I definitely did have these three or more symptoms.
I had the restlessness, I wasn't sleeping,
I was tense, every one of her boyfriends
could have sensed my irritability, and all of that.
So we are actually able to get this.
It's quite a common condition, as I allude to.
I don't mean to minimize it.
So it's chronic, over six months, over multiple events,
and they have at least three of the following symptoms.
It's actually more common than panic disorder,
and about 5%, two to one ratio.
Similar to panic disorder, more women than men.
Its age of onset is commonly in childhood.
If you ask adults who have this
about their anxiety in childhood,
they'll describe themselves as worriers,
worry warts, other things like that as they were growing up.
It's chronic, but fluctuates at periods of stress,
i.e. daughter dating.
And then it's the treatment again, trend.
You notice a trend here, SSRIs, SNRIs, and CBT.
It's not uncommon for people
with generalized anxiety disorder to have panic disorder.
Social phobia is when there's fear or anxiety
that surround being in a situation
that's where you can be criticized by others.
This can be a party, this could be giving a talk
in front of others, okay?
That's typically called performance anxiety.
And those situations provoke intense anxiety
every time you're in those situations, okay?
It's actually more common
than the other ones we talked about,
with up to about 10 to 13% of patients developing it.
It has an onset in adolescence.
More common across the population in females,
but in specialty centers, for whatever reason,
when you talk about it, seems to be more common in males,
in at least the treatment settings.
And very common comorbidity is depression
and actually substance uses.
People with chronic social phobia
tend to try to address that with alcohol sometimes.
The pharmacotherapy is, if it's really chronic,
generalized kind of social phobia about any situation,
we tend to schedule SSRIs.
If it's performance related, we can use PRN benzodiazepines
or PRN propanolol.
And again, cognitive behavioral therapy is often optimal.
Specific phobia is that intense fear
about a specific situation or object,
i.e., heights, spiders, snakes, those kind of things.
When confronted with the object,
almost invariably, you have a resulting panic attack
or intense anxiety or fear.
Think Indiana Jones in that pit of spiders,
that kind of stuff.
Lifetime prevalence is about 10%.
And interestingly enough,
fears tend to change from younger age to older age.
The most common fear in an elderly individual,
you guys know what that is?
It's actually falling, all right?
It doesn't have a specific phobia name,
but in screening patients about their fears in elderly,
it's often falling.
The pharmacotherapy, not in elderly patients
with the fear of falling, are PRN benzodiazepines,
if it's kind of an infrequent thing,
such as flying or things like that,
but the best treatment is, again,
that cognitive behavioral therapy,
getting to the root of the concern
and correcting those cognitive misinterpretations.
Again, my trend of anxiety as a symptom,
what could be causing it?
We have these very physiological things such as hypoxia.
Medications, a common medication, actually,
can be antidepressants that are started too rapidly
in patients with anxiety, will make anxiety worse.
And then dopamine antagonists,
the Thorazine we use for nausea,
the Haldol we use for antipsychotics,
those cause a side effect called akathisia,
that often mimics anxiety.
All right, in randomly controlled trials,
drug versus placebo, which of the following treatments
fail to demonstrate any efficacy or benefit
in the treatment of GAD, generalized anxiety disorder:
antidepressants, benzodiazepines, beta blockers,
or cognitive therapy?
All right, 50/50. This is good.
I like this.
All right, so let's talk a little bit about this.
So the SSRIs and the SNRIs are the first line treatments
for all of those anxiety disorders we've talked about,
panic disorder and other anxiety disorders.
Why?
Because they work across those disorders,
as well as depression,
and comorbidity is often more the rule than the exception.
When they work, the patient no longer experiences
any anxiety, which is key.
That's very different than PRN benzos, okay?
That requires somebody to feel miserable
before they take something.
They're well tolerated and safe in overdose.
I don't also have to worry about physiological tolerance,
potential dependence developing
with these medications like I do.
Some of the key aspects to use them in anxiety,
and this is really key, is start low,
start at half of the normal dose
you normally would for depression.
So if you're starting Zoloft sertraline,
start at 25 milligrams for a week,
make sure they tolerate it.
You wanna avoid that activation and that anxiety
that occur with starting at too high a dose.
If they do well at 25 in a week, you can increase it,
and you gradually titrate the dose.
The good news is it's the same dose
you'd use for antidepressant,
is the dose you'd use for an anxiety disorder.
The bad news is it still takes four to six weeks to work.
This is where I feel benzodiazepines play a role.
I use long-acting scheduled benzodiazepines
for four to six weeks to allow the SSRI
or SNRI to work.
And I tell the patient when I start it
that they're coming off of it in six weeks.
I am tapering them.
It is not a long-term medication,
the clonazepam I would use in this case.
So they know when I start it,
it is not a long-term medication,
and that makes it a lot easier.
Not easy, a lot easier to come off of it.
Why? Because benzos work.
They work really well for anxiety.
I had a brain MRI, I tried it without a benzo,
I lasted, I am not kidding, four seconds, okay?
I got a Xanax. Only time I've ever took it.
I don't know if it did anything for the anxiety,
but that piece of wood I laid on was so comfy.
I mean, it works.
It works really well, okay?
And it works quick.
It also helps with sleep,
which is also an issue with anxiety.
Its risk is tolerance.
Physical tolerance can lead to dependence.
You end up chasing your tail with chronic benzodiazepines.
Works for a while, need to increase the dose.
Stops working, needs to increase the dose.
Tolerance develops, and it can be hell
to get these patients off benzos.
I'm sure we've all encountered those.
And then in the elderly, sedation, falls, memory impairment,
there's actually some data to suggest
that dementia may be a sequelae
of long-term benzodiazepine prescribing,
because if it's action on the hippocampus.
So this may be a controversial slide,
I really see no role for chronic benzodiazepine use
in patients with a chronic anxiety disorder.
Scheduled benzodiazepines may prevent the disorder,
but they cause more harm than good in my mind.
PRNs, unless it's very infrequent PRNs,
once a week, couple times a month,
and a patient can tolerate that degree of anxiety,
that can work, but I really don't want my patients
with frequent panic attacks to experience the panic attack.
I wanna stop that, so that's why I use the SSRIs.
Coming to the end here,
other medications used for anxiety.
Buspirone, it is only FDA approved
for generalized anxiety disorder.
It doesn't play a role in the treatment
of other medications.
The joke with buspirone,
it is everything you want in a medication,
i.e., no side effects, well, well tolerated,
but it doesn't do anything.
Only really works for generalized anxiety disorder.
In addition, sometimes you have to dose it TID,
which is a pain.
Nobody ever takes a medication TID,
and it takes a while to work.
Hydroxyzine actually has an FDA approval for anxiety.
It also has an FDA approval for acute disturbance
and hysteria, which is awesome.
We often use these as the PRN medication for anxiety
with patients with substance abuse issues.
It's pretty much just a sedating antihistamine.
You dose it at 25 or 50.
The FDA says you can dose it at 100 milligrams
four times a day.
I mean, they're just sleeping at that point.
It does have some anticholinergic side effects,
so I tend to avoid it in the elderly,
and it's quite sedating.
Propranolol is for performance anxiety.
When you are concerned about cognitive impairment,
you don't wanna dull them with a PRN benzodiazepine.
So if I get anxious when I'm speaking,
I would take propranolol, not a PRN Xanax,
but it's not effective for generalized anxiety disorder.
That's why it was the answer on the question.
Learn this the hard way.
I gave a patient 20 propranolol
before they were to give a talk.
They took it before they were to give a talk,
stood up to give the, and fell on their face.
So make sure that you tell the patient
to try the dose the day before,
and see how things go, that they don't get orthostatic
and things like that.
True story. I was a resident.
It was very traumatic.
So the key points from an anxiety and bipolar standpoint,
bipolar I is mania, bipolar II is hypomania.
Bipolar II can never have mania.
Avoid antidepressants as monotherapy
because of their risk of mood destabilization
in both bipolar I and bipolar II.
If you're gonna use an antidepressant,
they should be on another mood stabilizer.
Valproate, not a friend in childbearing.
And then the SSRIs are considered first line
for anxiety disorders,
and always cognitive behavioral therapy on exam.
All right, I'm gonna turn it over here.
Thank you very much. I appreciate it.
(bright music)